Hi, I'm Riley.
I'm 24 years old and I want to become an athlete.
So I decided to sign up for an Ironman 70.3.
I can't believe I just did that.
And over the next four months of training, my goal is to become one.
This is the Ironman series.
Let's just say I had a pretty late night last night.
It was fun, but I got like three hours of sleep.
So I plan on doing this swim at 6am, but it's basically 8.15.
Worth it though, to the pool we get.
Ironman training has really been teaching me to work with the punches, prioritize training and pushing myself, but also reminding me that there will be days and weeks when it's gonna be hard to show up.
Or the workouts may feel really difficult.
But I'm gonna trust the training process and hope that all the hours of work that I do put in will carry me through this race.
I have a swim in a bike...
It's a bike brick session today, so I'm just headed to the pool for an hour long swim of lots of 100s.
And then we've got just a one-hour easy bike, so let's get it done.
So I'm doing 800 frees, and the first 25 meters is going to be a part-rate zone 6 is the goal.
And then the last is zone 4.
Let's do this.
We are working hard today.
Let's do it.
Sorry man, you're sick.
No fun.
Got like two seconds to rest, so here we go again.
I'm not gonna lie guys, that was a hard workout, but we did it.
And now I just have to do a 200-yard cool-down.
And I'm gonna do my favorite drill, which is pull with paddles.
And then we're done.
Before starting this training block, I had heard about the tough side of endurance sports and body image.
We did it!
Woo!
But then I decided to add period recovery on top of this process, which has just led to it deaging me so much.
And I want to dive deeper into that later in this video.
Great session done!
Today we are running and I'm actually at a track because I've got an interval session, which I haven't done in many moons.
Yeah, it's gonna be hard, but it'll be good.
To help me train for the running portion of my triathlon, I've been using Runa, a personalized automated running coaching app.
Runa offers plans from your first 5k to a 10k PR plan or marathon training and everything in between.
This video is obviously sponsored by Runa, so of course I'll be sharing my favorite things that I love about it with you, but I also do that outside of videos too.
I recommend Runa to anyone who wants to get into running because I genuinely think it's the best running coaching app out there.
I just think it's really easy to use and really, really easy to customize based on your own specific goals.
I used it to train for
I'm currently one step into my run.
I didn't sleep very well and I just don't think I'm gonna be able to give this workout my best.
So I'm gonna do three miles and then make up the rest probably tomorrow.
It's interesting in training there's this balance of listening to your body but also making sure that you're not just not showing up.
For me today I drove here I got out on this run with every intention of giving in my best and if today I can't give the 100% I'm gonna give the percent that I can and then I'm gonna keep moving forward.
Over the course of filming this video, I did need someone.
And you can see my performance dropping a little bit because instead of prioritizing early morning workouts and making sure I finish every single workout on my plan, there's a little more give and take.
And a shift in my priorities that I honestly think is perfectly okay because that's what comes with getting to know somebody better and prioritizing spending time with them.
And if that means I have to give up a couple good workouts, that's a sacrifice that's worth it.
I just ran into the store and picked up some cottage cheese.
And by the time I get home, I'll be done with my run.
I love pairing to-dos, going for a run.
And it turns it into more of an adventure.
I know I just posted a video about fixing my sleep, but right after I filmed that video, I traveled.
So went through time change, and then came back here, and then an unexpected development occurred.
For six hours!
Which has made it really hard for me to get to sleep.
Every day this week, I've stayed up between 1 and 3.30 in the morning, but we do have an indoor bike today.
I didn't get up early enough to do all of it before church this morning, so...
So I'm just gonna do as much as I can, probably just an hour.
I might make up the rest of it later, but I also might not.
Over the last couple months, I've started making it a habit to study for my personal training certification while I'm biking.
I put my phone right here, and then I just read while I cycle.
And it's a good multitasking moment.
I am many months into training for my Iron Man and my VO2 Max training.
In the last couple weeks, I've honestly not been hitting the numbers or the miles or the distance that I need to, and I just feel like I'm not doing a good job right now.
There are a lot of things I'm feeling, but that is one of them.
But I'm trying.
And that's what's most important.
So I'm trying to be patient with myself.
I got four hours of sleep last night.
I stayed up till 5 a.m.
And I was hoping to do a 10 mile run today because I haven't done a workout yet this weekend.
It's Wednesday, but I only had time for seven.
Even though I didn't run the exact distance I wanted to, I showed up and I did my best.
That makes me feel good, even though I didn't get the 10 miles I initially wanted to.
Now I'm gonna go take a shower and go to a play with my roommates.
I have so much to update you guys on.
A good place to start is the fact that I have been slacking.
I've been slacking so much in the training department.
Ever since I went on my trip to Florida, after getting back from that, I've just had so much going on and...
Training just has not been my highest priority.
But it needs to be because in less than two weeks, I'm going to be doing my Ironman 70.3 race and I want to feel prepared and good during the entire experience.
I did complete a 100 mile bike race, which made me feel a lot better in the cycling department.
So now I at least feel confident in my ability and have actually finished each of the distances that I'll be doing in the Ironman 70.3.
Now we just got to put them together.
My goal...
I've also been very last minute with this, but I got a wetsuit.
I still haven't done an open water swim with it.
So that's something we're going to be doing this week.
I also ordered a couple of different trisuits.
And also, I don't know if you can see these packages back here, but I'm going to get that set up right now.
And then I've got, then I've got to lock in guys.
I've got to lock in.
I've got an hour and a half easy spin on the bike.
And then I've got an off the bike run.
The bike is set up and ready to go.
I've got a one hour and 20 minute ride and I'm going to study for my personal training certification.
But that's kind of my thing.
Every time I ride indoors, I study on my phone.
And this is like creating the perfect setup for me to be able to do that.
Buying these shirts has honestly been so helpful to me.
When it comes to body image and working out, going through this period of time, it just helps me focus outward.
Let's go run!
Guys, this run has felt so good.
So good!
I'm so happy about it.
It's been way too long.
But we're in a 50 meter pool, which I haven't actually done an entire practice in.
So I'm really excited to see how it feels.
I'm supposed to do a 100 kick, but I don't have my kickboard.
I forgot it.
So I'm going to do 100 pull with paddles and then 100 without paddles.
Another day, another bike ride.
Today we've got an hour and 20 minute easy ride, and this is the first day that I'm trying out my tri-suit.
I think I'm just gonna cycle in it like this, and then for my runs and stuff, I'll try it out this week as well.
But for now, I'm just gonna test out this padding and see how I feel about it.
This is a really nice tri-suit, so I have high hopes for it.
I think it'll be good.
I love this bike.
From Swift, it's actually incredible.
Last time I cycled on it, I cycled barefoot, and I'm gonna do the same thing today.
Because I don't have clip and pedals for it.
I did order some, but they're not gonna get here until next week.
I'm trying this honey stinger bar for fuel very much.
Rad today.
I really do like the wafers that they make, and I think I'm gonna get some of those for my actual race.
It's okay, I'm gonna be fine.
It's mine.
Like, when I'm bendy down, it's like...
What's hard for me about the way that I feel right now is that I am not the same person that I was the last time that I looked like this.
I am not her in so many ways.
I am a much more disciplined and dedicated.
I'm a person that has more knowledge than she had and more ability to execute on my goals.
And it's just hard when I feel like my appearance doesn't match me.
And I just have to say with that because the way that I look in my body is not the most important thing.
I'm so glad that my body...
I'm so glad that I have my cycle back and I want it to be regular and that's important to me.
That's more important to me than not having this.
It's more important to me.
So I'm just gonna be here.
I'm gonna be here in this and I'm gonna feel good about it.
And I'm gonna be so grateful that I have this extra body fat right now because it's helping my body feel safe and it's just helping me be healthier.
Even though that doesn't really make sense.
This isn't forever.
I'm not gonna look like this forever.
It's okay that I look like this right now.
But it does stress me out.
And it doesn't make me feel my best.
And it's okay to recognize that.
It's okay to want to change it.
It's okay to not want to be this way or to feel this way.
But what's most important to me is that my body is healthy from the inside.
And if this has to happen for me to be that way, then bring it on because...
I can handle it.
This is a challenge just like any of the other challenges that I've done.
And it's all gonna be okay.
I feel like I'm not the biggest fan of this suit.
These arms, like, kind of long, but I could roll it up like this.
If I look legit though, I feel feel legit.
I did not plan on doing a double-edgeday, but I also didn't plan on spontaneously flying to New York City tomorrow morning.
So we're doing a double session, so I'm gonna do my hill workout today and then take tomorrow as more of a rest day because I'll be traveling all day long.
Is it kind of crazy to do this a week from my race?
Yes.
Am I doing it anyway?
Also, yes.
Let's go.
Guys, I'm so amped about this trip.
My heart rate is like 160 in the warm-up.
So I'm walking because I need to chill the heck out.
We've made it to the hill.
I've never been on just a regular run that's felt like a race.
I did have a gel for halfway, but it fell out somewhere.
I'm currently in New York City.
I've been here for the last week.
And it's been fun to train for my triathlon here.
I'm currently one week out from my Ironman 70.3.
But one exciting thing is that I actually got the opportunity to come up to run the New York City Marathon.
So I'm going to be using RUNNA to train for that marathon.
So I'm going to create a new training plan to help me post If you've been wanting to train for and run a race, but you don't know how to get started or don't know very much about running, I highly recommend using Runa to create your own personalized training plan.
And if you're interested, you can click the link in my description.
We're using Code Riley to get a two-week free trial.
There's also a QR code on the screen, so you can also scan that.
I hope you guys do.
I hope you guys do because it's awesome!
And I'm really excited for my Iron Man coming up in one And I'm also really excited to run the New York City Marathon.
That's like a bucket list race for me and...
I know I alluded to it in my running video, but I do want to run lots of races next year.
And I feel like this is a good way to kind of ease into more longer distance running races for next year.
And it's not really exciting.
Thank you guys so much for watching this video too.
I hope you enjoyed it.
And I'm excited to bring you along for my Ironman race.
And I will see you in the next video.
Bye guys!
Bye!